[Music]
what's going on people getting this
thing set up we're gonna have some
guests in the building this moved
actually chilling it coming Lords are
coming just getting everybody set up
dizzy was going on us company yo y'all
up in here okay I see what's going dead
singer what's going on
[Music]
[Music]
him from surgery we have five 650 okay
good or thank you scrub nurse deep-sea
tale it was good all Christopher Hall is
going down he got his jay-z music let's
go the king is back that's what we doing
whole whole whole season who's good all
mixers in the building thank you mixing
for working Thank You twitch for working
the king is coming the king is coming
Shane you already don't choke it ninja
what's going on so anyone in chat I see
y'all be all yes the beard what's going
on
Cristobal got heat Brooklyn stand up
jay-z music all that sure oh yeah
we doing roll star laughs attic talk to
the people cuz of a hobbit waiting for
this day I'm telling you right now you
bout to get all his balls off you better
get a whole socio need yours that's the
grind at Flay's desert ELISA oh brother
good to see you back loving destiny
again I had to keep talking can you hear
me I'm I have to get I'm at the nuke
this tree cuz um no Kings come to our
town oh you sound low for me is that
better yeah sweet dog from mixer what's
going on thank you thank you Black
History Month you know spinal you've got
like nine people this beastie is like
he's a Nintendo guy like that that shows
how crazy is following is like Oh daddy
the legend the legendary
what's going on seafood poetic
exhibition it was some death was going
on
I don't know I forgot about bad definite
I forget I'm trying to get on ladies and
all that was going on
yes yoni doors I want to hear you
complaining you can't be happy now and
then be complaining every week about
that's D ain't doing this
you spend a hundred hours in the season
he said it's fine let's again look at
VG's stuff no geez all you doing destiny
[Music]
what I'll do is I'm actually mute the
string for a little bit because we can't
have that copyrights right so y'all
gonna be silent for a little bit we'll
come right back I'm gonna go to the
store recording you something to drink
before it starts
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let me up they're gonna take is the kick
is around we doing another sound check
right quick kiss moving to bill the kid
talk to the people kids in the bushes
heap I left already
yo we got PlayStation royalty up in the
building place woo was going on brothers
talk to the people right quick I get my
Saudi baby I need that keep those
expectations in check
the kick is it a bit of wastes all this
so this might be sauce first live stream
yo so we just getting it ready this is
when he make the power switch
[Laughter]
playstation jacket put that drip right
now blaze to King right that is a battle
gone or yeah I don't know is a stuntin
battle right now the cameras right quick
Sam between King and blazing the front I
love that Sony Sun that's right that's
how you do it man you come to this
building you represent that generated
only don't fall back you all that same
energy 100% all the way to go for Chris
Chris been waiting for this minute since
since the moment they told him they had
a chipset ready they still got a chip
that thing I know system why you get the
fraud alert on stage what's that about
it was one old maybe Twitter chat think
that like button y'all hit that like
button please please hit that like
button I we just gonna sit tight Mitch
I'll give it five more minutes and then
um I don't know where song but I'm about
to give solve a call make sure he got
the link
you can lick him I'm gonna because he
had stuff to do yeah that's true that's
true electric eye job Oh slow slow beau
said he is here put a foot only we have
a lot of food just going on today
Oh hundred percent 100% pure foolish mo
we will wake up on Saturday brother I
will show you the complicated 15-minute
setup that we've been doing hey J hey J
[ __ ] when I came
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I think it's just it's one of these
things like if they like the Streisand
effect they just need to show it some
people love how it looks
sales or anything I think it would be a
shame if they didn't take the Sony Jake
like which looks pretty cool right I can
get a console that's just an abomination
like a 32x style they made Omaha
clicking anything bricks on my on my my
shelf and I would really like something
to stand out so I can hear what I think
we're gonna be way too well that's the
one thing I didn't bring them up with
you know sometimes it's about like the
consoles almost disappearing right and
like Xbox oh you just play here that
feels like at least based on the
controller might be really interesting
what this looks like to bring bring back
the head to travel with the costume play
where games are gonna go and you said
you know I think
that's what I used to put the see the
event we are obviously watching the the
feed here live have to turn it down lies
beyond with the place in there streaming
on the PlayStation the thunderstorm in
ooh yes yeah oh yeah you know what's
coming we got a $2.00 super-tough from
Jeremy oh oh no we got that one that's
the Box it's gonna take inform transform
and form 1080p
go home you stupid you say they're gonna
March 30th
a little of - I like Xbox but I doesn't
want to see the oh yes enhanced enhance
[Music]
pulled up showing up and I'm gonna show
you right now just over a year since we
began sharing technical details of
PlayStation 5 today's the day that we've
been looking forward to three years we
get to show you just some of the games
that demonstrate our belief that
playstation 5 mocks the biggest
generational transition yeah
industry has yet the content was pure a
registration showcases how PS 5 has
inspired developers to create new
experiences that are transformative and
how they look sound and feel enough for
me yeah that looks way better go to the
PlayStation 3 I'm not doing it they put
me to sleep we get some talking in our
house where is that spider-man go ahead
relax
please don't do that he was right oh
it's your turn I'm telling you that I
want to see gameplay let's come next
holiday where is the controller Miles
Morales captured on PS 5 be greater when
we get that only just like peaceful no
it could just be an expansion hold on oh
it looked just like here we go oh good
answer this moan oh hey joho yes ma also
not good no oh damn what oh I'm coming
I'm coming
see whatever done sorry y'all
I don't give two shits about this but I
know a lot of people radically better
with yet a stream look way better thank
you had a kid does that tree
gt800 what you predicted very smart
obviously that's gonna happen on that
was on the list all right the key is
real quick y'all that's fine
do we think spider-man is DLC for orders
that's a PA that's what it seems like
new spider-man that's crazy
Wow force a wheel yet yeah gran turismo
is back but it just okay there we go now
it's this gameplay guys that kid you
messy weapon I'm just saying this is not
gameplay this is a blur
this is not putting any fear in for the
spine super chat am i watching the flea
market pirated movie would stream and
the quality we knew was 1080p 30 frames
per second shout out the cat boxes they
said Spidey's dlc they wouldn't name it
Molly yeah you right
I'm gonna tell you right now this is a
this is horribly not a game ladle if you
don't shut up console today it's over
if you don't show confidence like
curious with you guys like right now
like I'm not a racer like new place
racers that for some reason just what
I've seen on four is it like it looks it
looks better than this like you know I
don't say you know the craziest thing
about the hood this looks like it can be
done on your Playstation 4 Pro charge on
the beach ostrich at the last 12 floors
just look better - yo you missing Wow
like cuz the great regular like Gran
Turismo and regular Forza Motorsport
that's like sim racing like that's
racing in a circle like yo guys the
warranties Pro Bowl you sitting do you
notice the lack of cause y'all that see
buddy there's only one hey but one thing
we can't say is they're giving game
after game thank you stupid is the ex my
life like titled grounded this already
looks better the ground yeah all a head
this is gonna come out launched right
this is
so far I want to know what's actually
coming into that place
this looks fun man yeah this looks like
words we're ratchet Clank need to go
they're actually plate dimensions that
look very nice
where's the but there's a but somewhere
it is no but this is one of my favorite
franchises yeah now King plays that
ratchet that this is one of our favorite
franchises from no I listened it was at
the launcher yeah yoson okay so now
we're seeing the SSD in effect you see
it switching from world to world right
you see we see no now is it practical is
there a world thing cuz I'm also seeing
a frame rate or drugs but I'm not having
a problem with it because I also know
that this is early in development and
looks very good I love it
the question is is this day wonderheart
alright I don't think they're you know a
dub is the shelter I looks like doctor
straight no date it don't look like day
one though with you that ratchet rift
apart a brand new full-length
interdimensional adventure built from
the ground up for the PlayStation 5
we're doing things we've never been able
to do before
okay from planet to planet nearly
instantly or put raytrace reflections on
Clank all of our worlds are filled with
density and life previously unseen plus
ratchets all new arsenal is more
exciting than ever thanks to the dual
sense controllers enhanced feedback
ratchet and clank are near and dear to
our hearts at insomniac and we can't
wait to share more with you in the
future but from watching it I'm gonna do
the Spanish Oh busy the precipice breath
yeah just get your breath I'm honestly
gonna tell you right now is it's time
that you playing this baby because I
know everybody at kinky King know what
this looks like now I'm gonna tell you
this I this makes me believe that that
spider-man really is a dlc difference
the problems working you know I wasn't
gonna threaten insomnia I wasn't gonna
do the ratcheting crack that will get
handed on somebody else right and I want
you to ask a serious question
so this look that much better than the
ratchet acquainted you have for one of
the managers to go back and look at this
watch how to explain to people the next
generation is a little subtle to startle
today it's hard to show close we at a
point you know guys we had a tipping
point this is as beautiful as this look
you can't tell me that this can't be
done on a Playstation 4 all intro can
they never max s system out oh my god
come this one day one this is me
throwing that bomb I'm collecting on my
with my hate in real familiar
I need a Carlito I know I know but look
at all my boobs like everything flying I
love all that this is not nothing I
cannot see on a regular PlayStation 4
bro when the world is blowing up then
you pull in the world in that little
crook see all the stuff we talked about
rate racing and stuff like that you're
not gonna be able to see that on they're
gonna see them like but really rate
racing game look great though right no
game looks for now it looks fun 1080p
don't forget oh that's three men oppress
I told you I would be happy and a lot of
those great ecstatic about to lose it
adecuado day one right now
nevermind luminous luminous know what
this is
the final fantasy the next one
you have the next Final Fantasy let's go
what's this all let's go was this might
be for me yeah purchasing in the project
okay
but that wasn't gameplay oh that look
who I got already I just want to know
what's coming this year oh nothing
brother you get the DLC for the Spider
Man definitely get b-12 give me a b12
shot there's some nodoz man so what you
waiting for y'all better angle with a
bang cuz we're already half an hour in
show's almost over folks this what you
came for no you still just got that I'm
telling you what y'all be talking about
y'all be talking about this day for a
minute all week long still not nervous
you comfortable it is like how are you
in my circle y'all getting knocked out
in July they got a cat in the window he
like no place I know all blaze is that
interesting while nobody's interested
it's almost a Buddha this gay all the
cat did
linguist man I think I passed I think
the cat the cat catch there is the king
because we gotta get up out of here you
got a game about a straight the
PlayStation is delayed to February 2021
stray cat it's okay maybe this is maybe
your Dalek race for the controller four
months ago show something else man look
at it sugar playing in the dirt project
deal look look look hot
or hot hot we got a headphone jack
audio 3 the audio K you're greedy
okay audio it's my stomach bang &
olufsen go breath you pick the wrong
time between the artistic and technical
limitations my burdened like that I'm
gonna be able to realize our artistic
vision a lot better it's got a ton of
horsepower which is very easy to unlock
school and it's a machine the name is
Herman belabor my his wife will present
a paradigm shift as to water I'm
comparing between under will let us
touch stories make worlds frequently
invited you are to fate the player and
reason Mars by the fluids bring
something please take a look at this new
franchise for world with CEOs coming
exclusively trying for places you want
peace let's go IP WAP set exclusive
cakes car IP to the new IP yeah loss
game down they said this might present I
think it's gonna be a resogun win is not
a new I be true what if it's good look
like this this is a player this is what
is this look like a trailer so so far
the inside the Xbox is smashed in the
soul the highlight is the street
let me rock this might be for beetle
this thing for you sorry this is like
some massive why is it moving so slow
Wow 30 frames per second 1080p and it
can speed up to have a spider on his arm
there's no enemies outside it's just
grass oh my god it looks like it looks
like a death stride need to point over
we notice is officially to do so okay
now we see some enemies enemies all
right now I mean assam notice for me
this see me play after a row let's go
we end a one baby please
you gonna buy right now I like sci-fi
bro like this is me
it's our eternal this is garbage
had that been shown that anything from
Microsoft that have been booing us out
at least a notice notice no released a
your blaze I'm telling you right now
this is discussion about what y'all cost
me in gelato what's the great value Mass
Effect imaginal okay okay now I like
some old digital let's do it this Mac
Bobbsey returns there we go is the bean
with a cat is born y'all excited I am
NOT excited but
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I laughed the kids with Playstation 5
we are okay hello it's did you get that
I lost racing car a racing car smells
like and you can get out the car so you
can watch it you didn't come if you get
out it in the car that's kind of a
unique I think this is like rocket
League jumping in and out yes you need
these all right so you can the car okay
this is a weird way somebody said behind
it is - yeah Messi not laughing I won't
run it I'm in I'm in what is this I like
this
sunset overdrive yes this is probably a
day one stitch keep saying no release
date kraut your father's not happy they
said you only like one game no fun I'm
gonna be on audio
they'll already know I'm scheduling from
this video tell me if there's one game
you liked no it is nothing he likes
probe wrapping even like how how field
you're gonna disown that baby we're very
excited today to share with you the
first look at our new game it's a story
full of adventure they told us to put on
our tightest shirts to get this show
just look at very grounded hey grounded
this is the forum grounded y'all didn't
like grounded so nice
there's a lot of fat I go let's keep the
same energy or I go for though she I
kind of like the character model yeah no
she's out the bocal smiling with the 206
to the chat just laughing even though I
like it we got to keep same energy
Philly Eagle is right bro no there was
this game where they had to take care of
these lonely cute freaking marshmallows
looking things like this that's in this
game cameo vibes
yes proud yeah but what happens when
when the real cameo shows up and it's
knockoff right here gets now hey you you
know what you got to do don't you got a
week until July for greatness deficit up
just fabulous when it's all a nice lots
of it's cool but again the same energy I
like that she got the moon you know what
this why this game is so yeah quite a
bit this doesn't launch in the same
windows Ratchet and Clank now you see no
yeah
is release date there's no times they're
gonna do
it's a transition to trying to use those
logos to pick up some of the time oh yo
they had a good opening man think it
might be a rat let's go home get a blaze
so far only two games that was on the
list that was leaked to me has shown I'm
a cursor mouth in a minute
I don't be about you know what college I
don't care about animal FaceTime you
know what this reminds me it reminds me
of the ìiî that Microsoft had where we
felt like the beginning was good the
middle was trash and we thought the
ending was gonna make a lot of shadows
but it never did I said Oh College this
do feel very clean and cliquish why is
why are we looking at Chicago we miss it
on bonds new pajamas
it's a kicker and why are you burning
books Karen
we got Jonathan being with the 2000 so
glad they made a Yoshi game bro you got
it yeah I just heard you we won along
Robert jumping but could I was talking
when I was really mocha smiley with this
a sexy version of minions that date up
in the ship
oh my fault yeah 2021 right you keep
seeing to it so anyone I'm not liking
that remember I told Kiki were no no
that the better incognito you are giving
it along that's February rescuing is
rewarding failure is the morning Miami
area right and the memories should last
you take a look and um I need I'm gonna
need the same energy like plastic now
I'm gonna need the same energy for real
I think please teach me this is not this
looks like this looks like some people
I'd be killing on XCOM alright right now
I can see why
Phillie Eagles $2 which has same energy
is all I'm asking for no matter facts
yo this Sunday's going to be on fire on
fire because the joke talked about 20
games how you like that you read me the
babies performing for you your fame just
made a good point they made a good point
we shot the face designed exclusively
for ps5 means the game is exclusive
question mark the design part is
throwing me off that's gonna be the new
buzzword the new world well this isn't
me you're just a [ __ ] or onii-chan Alex
sigfig may be boys and says you know
can't you you you started suddenly to
give you your key Messi he puts a
picture of that force from the last
trailers that explosive banger
not like this nighlok they define it not
like this Sony not like this
first I will give them a console then
you're dizzy passion project multi plus
GG Mela finale's how about that anime I
can tell you in July I want you to Tony
how much is video and that's crazy
when halo gets on their screen it's I'm
mark Louie to us medium is gone kill
everything they show so I gonna say no
but I would put you onto some way
showing you polygons mr. Chang I know
hey Rob - to the check come on Sony they
show m1 they're gonna show one fire game
in sa stay tuned the internet will block
for this show damn shame keep the same
tactic no I think I think if they don't
start showing some decent games
I think the Internet's gonna climb up
right here look like this right here
looks like VR you're kind of done it
kind of done this right here looks like
the are but like not telling anything
that this is VR
this is purposely misleading
maybe I don't was it worth person I
don't remember
they didn't show this in this book this
looks hot garbage it's a good thing so
he did go to e3 because this would
destroy but zombies great a big cagiva
dizzy you Betsy
I remember that name too another logo a
feeling of Spades room is going to floor
my dude I'm trying to amp it another
[ __ ] looking game yeah but it's on Sony
you can't flirt man the ID at Xbox is
smashing his whole drink ace delivery
and execution God can bleed looking like
Jordan right now the 45 was rapid
yeah I'll tell you what that PS 5 SSD is
hard at work right now
Yoda said we'd be a vestibule LP abyss
yeah I can see the transitions your
thought Joe was called walkers the font
it's not all away lik come on Chris I
need your query right now then just keep
going with this like they have to look
blaze let's be right here this is on
inside Xbox you wouldn't even remember
what it is yo Chris slow-mo say this is
another path but you know who's a
problem with them right always they
showing all these smaller games so they
realized they were Xbox was doing was
the right thing right you got a
spotlight these games the thing is Xbox
has game pass to highlight them and I
don't see the graphics of way worse than
them we said graphics not resolution
[Music]
exclusively on the alright this is
February help me help help you did it
again Sony's back at it again kids move
this is this is the bangers this is it
that's how they survived in the ps3 era
they were all about this they were all
about this you wasn't down with them
then now you can't you can't jump on the
ps4 bandwagon like this has always been
it that's not
there's gotta be a diversity goes
perfect unto us which is about to mop
the floor with you jump on a Sony
bandwagon thought the PlayStation 5 was
gonna be it no breath out of baby do it
all I know all I know is you better come
with the IOP Sunday with some with
substance bag so let's all show the
console energy have you noticed we
haven't seen anything people been saying
like the rise of the evils
I told us a lot of time raise it in two
hours a night if they got a big enough
space out floors in oh there we go
finally something hitman hitman hitman
you know I still like it man I love it
man is awesome
yeah it goes game past date and a game
all your hard work I got sleep for this
all your sacrifice I'll see a pony sped
up the process in my Martin voice damn
damn damn so once we've had 45 minutes
of trash
[Music]
they'll stitch there one hour yourself
[Music]
awaits in Plato where's that energy
installation I'm gonna tell you right
now was coming over a ohio style second
reason 47 is back for his most intimate
and professional country we feel
definitely - when you lie I know you are
bored right now you're crazy
oh sorry
only babies
[Music]
Kelvin is running oh my god yes did you
grew a big
ooh - stop stop deflecting this is a
PlayStation show you see right now you
probably saw one game that'll make you
safe
are you gonna drop that baby no you drop
it $700 Oh is the casual you are where's
his red ball or shrunken ninja to our
super charity inside Xbox curse haha
this game is pretty though matt is
artistically I didn't like the cancer
part but I like the porellos they are
what's from the call it right now
they're in a weird zone but they're
trying to show you why you need to buy a
Playstation 5 and right now right okay
we'll see no blaze like I just like as
far as like a lot of times the bankers
take more time look to comment longer
recycle right traditionally I've just
I've been trying to tell people they're
launched you just said they did the
Indies and all this other stuff so when
Microsoft showed you third party the
other day no I love this show no no no
no I'm not about you mo all of it all
over their head yeah it was gonna hit I
love that show the kids these anyway you
like this nine extra got it right the
last one keeps coming back to sovereign
being right
that's grounded I said you know listen
you know garbage oh yes Wow please aim
at the SSP
[Music]
over here to put into the butchers for
this listen into the bush put it all
down you see you forgot I want you guys
to continue putting those bushes right
now you're drinking the kool-aid going
getting energy drinks taking a blue but
here's a little color for you having to
watch this garbage
gee babe $10 to check into the bushes
let's get some into the bushes in there
for Gmail you say they got a walking
hoagie in the game you got your
breakfast
what is this junket for the indie game
mafia pulled up on sodium let's get some
buildings in that chapter
let's get bend the knees in that job bro
I think right now let's get some bend
the knees in that chair I don't see
nothing to make me buy a Playstation 4
shooting thank you son for pulling up
from my joint son they go show horizon
to the show yes before we get to the end
of the show
they're gonna show horizon in the show
okay that's good oh my god
horizon is launched if for us is lost a
hell no it's not launched are you let
this right let this run your saga wow
this is part of fantasy
although the demon souls yes yes Oh
Jamison
talk to him blaze blaze this I know I
know
yeah I feel a blue H apostrophe here
good guy blue stand up is falling them
so let's go this is the hardest soul
fight game ever made
yeah this this is original game at all
was the instrumentation play we just
wanna be played there's a remake of the
original it was the game yeah January 20
2006 world why do I came here go to
loads of gaming dotnet blow elbow is up
right now Jean
[Music]
exclusive banger all I'm seeing is
trailers where is oh hi kuzon yeah this
looks awesome we happy few so this is VR
just appeared
they say this is VR this doesn't look
this [ __ ] started by
people to me I'd rather have a disorder
3 than whatever the hell this is yeah
yeah okay art style right oh we could
rework oh yeah
Belize think about it this way also
Bethesda jalopy the new VR headset gonna
have a booth is not being you know if
this is oh this is the other one they
showed the rewind one one it was talking
about before remember yeah and when they
showed it but we said I did now mix any
colors if you have that rewind ability
do not hit it when it comes to this like
this honor just has a way more better
imma give it a run good you know but
this is multiplex oh yeah I don't care
where this comes from I'm not playing a
shout out so much with Spencer soon
appear really a sober song we got those
yeah you know you know what we gonna do
ski check we're gonna wait for this to
hit game back that's all I'm doing right
now a shout-out to the no man's sky go
to any path right now
no man that was already insane Tomblin
father five pounds which at disability
budget needs to be raised when the knees
King is taken is already blazing our
plane no no he thought he wanted those
to say I want to cook that whole section
that whole section was I couldn't stop
laughing I was literally I was worried
for my life yeah I was I'm not gonna be
able to maintain profession is that 60k
grounded
[Music]
blaze this is it this is it horizon zero
dawn Sahil
all right let's go thank you now let's
get to the finishing off my list is one
more game Oh an hour in right so we got
another hour left no we more than an
hour in he said that that we're about to
end up graphic Gus and what is a box of
nice smell like alright everyone be
quiet trying to hear it you got knees
right then a box
what is it that creepy story it's just a
local tale I know and it's a whole hour
and we still a see nothing yet all right
like the curtain gets shot them up and
looks like this might evil is present
evil yeah maybe Wesley wait could be
yeah they said that was on Elizabeth I
don't think so yeah this is the evil eye
this might be silent it no it looked
like resident evil the reason why it
looks like wasn't able they give you the
shield they gave you the soil right yeah
see Tori comes to an end
I don't know it's only story this looks
like star style no game I'm liking it
ninjas are in resident village yeah I
like it multi-play Christmas is bet on
eggs
no I see killing people yeah Oh
Christopher Lee yo krysta feel I'm
buying it it's the villain I mean you
play the no hero DLC no no I didn't yeah
[Music]
ky yeah he was right guy he's studying
us quit the seven real was better though
mmm-hmm Navi are can't even do that vo I
had to take it off I had to play record
stranding we edition this looks like a
death stranding thing this is what's
that game sonic filter know with the see
this is that platinum game it on crisis
no this is that platinum game in this
look very platinum cats coming from
another trailer this one play go
straight cat the whole day cat this is
where's the game play doh
what is this like what game is this
we've been waiting for you oh [ __ ] oh
the cat skeleton is showing dollar super
check they haven't showed me anything
that I want to spend olive oil still
platinum and I love it I love crazy you
compromised me
okay notnot Vanquish to bankers one look
way better and it's makes it don't brag
meta it don't matter
this passion project okay how far you
think okay copy go get in this game
before you drop these date I'll be
ending these games you see mom's doing
it that's the captain game that
everybody's talking about I guess bushes
he's not buying none of this 2023 I'm
done
do not listen to cog I'm telling y'all
right now no back my hands oh I'm gonna
tell you right now all the stuff that he
gasps y'all team is first why let's go
oh this the whole team if they ignore
the gorilla wasn't that logo give me
good well again this is the end of the
angle we need a bed rasa tea screen now
it can't be there it can't be the end of
your show voice yes
this look crazy yeah but we already know
game play dirty alright same energy
yeah there we go this is what you look
like PlayStation 4 does it does it not
yes baby this is e 3 for them thank
please they gotta I want to see a moving
around in that world what's going on
yeah
I like you want the water can you loan
up joint mountain pass they won't
explore right whoo alligator alligator
I'm the water
where'd he know that's gonna look
incredible no secret I want along
no barrier I won't cross
the if this isn't handle silent dude
we'll start the show with this they made
it to set it off like we got some follow
black people we got lucky
they're low-key just put him in there
last check baby forbidden West land of
the black people
horizon coming to Steven comes I don't
know about the name but used to coming
to steam don't say it's the choir
I purchased the game I actually got the
game I'm actually one but I got to
finish the first one first rise in
forbidden West yo this was the highlight
my son now it's when
fade to black you know welcome to the
new Sony this is the sign it's all
inclusive we care about you that we feel
that we're under Jim dance with Ryan we
only watch the control and a logo don't
show the system this is an epic fail
thing y'all are done and
hmm this is a perfect way to show it now
this is a logo bro problem it's a
concept let's go get it for me oh yeah
mommy let's go come on how does it look
Oh
shaking don't say anything if you hear
no one say anything if you see it first
the number logo looks like a pyramid
hold on Robert Olson
Ben dummies forms a thank you there's
got to be the collet so this is an owl
just feeding us like this like you put
my balls in a room pose
[Music]
[Applause]
and you know what again in somebody's
hand sad news
wait the breath isn't that going to
confuse the people
medium or distance if this is 640 bad
money okay this is the reason why I'm
talking about it mom again who loves to
tell you the heads in our webcam yo I
bet you enjoyed the first glimpse of our
future too now that you know how a more
striking console design yet can you sing
games that can only be enjoyed with the
full range of playstation fives coaches
empower a playstation easily
generational trainer making them happen
we want you to enjoy the unique benefits
of moving from one generation to the
next purchase oh I don't like the top
what other them at least they showed him
in he had to show you know it's weird
for the sake of looking weird
they had come out with it I also told
everybody that is shout out the grappler
standing soul Thank You Brad not a great
shot I was gonna go for you Brad anybody
that was listening that the Playstations
have a Final Fantasy wasn't here it was
a whack show but they definitely handed
to the fam families but they gave me
what I ask for
if they don't show the console this was
a it was a complete failure show you're
not a complete fail
did they troll the console so who said
that I feel like I got to go on Twitter
and attack people to set that other call
Howard slow me that show was made with
glad they showed the console oh they're
out now at the same time what's up in
July it
to cast it over nothing but I can tell
you in July the thief is getting knotted
how did I do these that same energy
please this was okay in there very
classy
you don't think soon will be a really is
didn't see this and laugh to death he
nicely I would like to see if he
responds this conference besides six
hundred dollars in your pocket right the
last 600 mm run enough Nesmith $2 it's a
quesadilla four-door done that's all
that's all I'm saying in your pocket you
got to pay rent that you a has no limits
that's 30 low take us back to Google
hangout oh all right so we can go back
to our show because this whole are bad
15 minutes King I agree look at it so we
get into it yo oh really
so let's get to it y'all let's get to it
the future out the dating rules final
super check I'm watching every live
event with y'all make any avert world
watch let's start it off with armed
place because blaze you are the epitome
of Sony you wear that drip you get busy
baby let's talk to me now give me your
overall thoughts your standouts way out
with this show brother yeah what's the
show
yeah okay but you know this is the I
mean when it comes down to function the
[ __ ] was garbage trash to show with my
trash we already know zero Horizons
Alma's none be there okay good show that
we already know that Ratchet and Clank
was gonna make a show of parents okay
good we good
they try to shove it off with a
spider-man that's the DLC let's keep it
real let's keep it a buffets do this
let's do this I did not see anything
there now make me want to go buy a
Playstation I'm about Playstations I'm a
hardcore dude I'll give him a break they
don't get my brother gardening and all
that oh we know they track record know
right now your track record is spotty
this is new this is disgusting holy
Jean is this stuff or it's for the class
back write your thoughts gonna clap back
I didn't get shot at all I told you when
I came in you heard the music that came
in children came in on g-unit I told you
and I didn't like nothing else oh but
I'm gonna tell you this down to a
constable beautiful yes you want to go
to the console let me give you my take
for risk oh there's no reference for
referral that controller I told you I
love the controller since day one yeah
use it a console I knew that was gonna
look better than Microsoft console right
fine now I see a strategy this is the
first time out of anything that they put
this strategy first they trying to take
the lead they told you that it's going
to be true so they trying digital
edition you trying to smoke xbox ow
yeah let's see what that Lockhart is
about we don't know
specifications that's on that that was a
no like I decided yeah I'm not sure yeah
if the thing is else I have the
advantage if this I don't think it's
gonna be weaker I don't think it's a
weaker box is the same I think it's a
different size hard-driving I think all
they're exactly trying to make it
cheaper ok question real quick though
like I'm relooking you know I want to
I'm gonna put this in the chat real
quick kognito bring this up in the in
the home we got super chess right now
Adam picks up Angie finally Alienware
tower design plus a full-on DRM console
sony dudes better say nothing crazy
again Jack dodge Jesse Darby $2.00 to
pitch I feel ignored by oh my bad Jesse
I don't know if we missed you before my
back Tita know me hold of the we did we
get perfect Shogun with the two la super
shy 499 399 for the digital okay then we
got Eagles fan 76 to the $2.00 who
protect questions why should I buy PS 5
day one again late station connect less
good look like I just said I just sent
you the picture of the PS 5 I don't
think you could put that horizontal it
looks like it has a curved edge no if
you look at it both sides are curved
yeah I'm looking at it right now we
won't know until late actually I mean
you can put anything down they don't
matter but again alright so we're
looking at the double skew right now all
the same energy things are they gonna
confuse the market would this be this
over how would that be this a whole new
question of how they gonna market that
second console and I think that second
console works for the $400 rings people
that want that 399 if that in there
right now that takes away something that
y'all conformed before which was pork a
real and the 4k and not the stream in 4k
is a lot of dudes bandwidth ain't up
there as
let's display that they show right now
we keep turning 30 right here here's
another picture of it
what's to happen with their messaging
because this is mixed messaging now you
show the console now you show to that's
you taking the lead but you left no
information that maybe that's gonna come
on the website all right I'm just
playing devil's advocate because I'm I
know what camp I'm in mm-hmm
and I'm not gonna for it and tell you
all the Xbox series X look better but I
know it performs better right so I
always told you I don't give a hell if
I'm looking at a toilet bowl if all the
bowls Mo Kio joint okay how nice your
joint my toilet bowl break yours in real
quick let me just put on a screen where
addicts sent me this is like especially
that second screen
it's definitely curved right don't you
take blade but don't you think that's
like a holder on the bottom - just hold
look show them the second one yeah that
stays Sony always nobody shows that it's
not flat okay I'm looking at the second
one now you're gonna have to fit it on
the outside of your does that look like
it's meant to be put on its side because
you say cuz is you seeing the curved
part but what about on the left side it
looks like it's a 360 kind of almost it
would be kind of foolish Freddy I I see
what you're saying it it I bet you I bet
you 20 bucks the fans are on the top and
it's meant to be set like that so
doesn't overheat hmm well what look at
that Bret yeah all right listen we got
well we got Eagles fan Eagle Spanish 76
- mm that it's vertical how am I gonna
put how am I gonna fit this talking to
him because you gonna put it outside of
your game a stack like you do your own
[Music]
your router your routers on the floor on
the side isn't right next year router so
we got a $10 chef from brat not a great
show up but we saw capabilities of next
gym with games horizon zero dawn 2 is
very impressive as a first-party ps5
sky's the limit with Sony first-party
console is sexy
I am look to be honest with you bro I
got to disagree the the big games they
showed besides Ratchet and Clank they
did not show gameplay
besides Ratchet and Clank like we got to
keep the same energy you guys it's you
like we want to see gameplay too let's
see what these games are gonna look like
on this but you're completely correct
but at the same time that's what we want
to see regardless if they promote it or
not is it not yeah exactly
I mean this is their e3 presentation
basically still had a week before they
didn't show shadow Simon break break two
pounds super check the place to age of
five look like a taco tell me I'm wrong
that's right right
I think this is ps5 is gonna be just as
tall as the Xbox series X just not as
built big like built like they're not
what I saw oh it's looking like they
literally put that the way it's designed
so you won't want to put it on your side
there we go see soggy gaming by a choice
with the file I switch at the consoles
look amazing but I liked xbox show
better shout to 309 in here y'all let's
get to you man oh I'm shot the brownie
about the going home I want to talk but
I got it I got a week because I got boy
I did kissable kid you have been getting
the heat the smoke they've been on you
supposed to have life better not come
outside
x-pac he took that oh he disgusted
breath that show was all right they
opened up well with this party man DLC
yeah and they like they showed a couple
things early as like all right so if
they're starting off strong and that
means they're maybe they're gonna show
everything from 2020 to 2025 United mean
just to give us height and then um that
stopped fairly quick and they started
showing a whole bunch of inside Xbox
games facts by their high just
we stopped saying inside Xbox I just
liked it I think the show was good but
it's just like look like once again with
a third party stuff that people attacked
everyone on third party they did not
show me what these games you're gonna
look like on next-gen I agree with King
retching clink don't look a whole lot
different than the first one it just
does it like you know III think people
didn't really like sit down and chew
that to the mic I only played three
hours of it and it looked almost
identical yeah yeah I'm talking about
dudes that didn't play the first one is
out here oh my god this might have been
good pacing but the context that was in
the pacing right was Hart guardian III
would agree the pacing was good they
just loved that song let's get stupid
transition with the kid get his bars off
I did I gotta guess I don't know if kid
finish get his bars off before and I was
was it finished but I was saying yeah
yeah like the content in the show was
just like yo dude this isn't this is
life for all the stuff I hear from these
PlayStation guys like and this is the
stuff we see you know they're smiling
this was Xbox yo you know this box so
people would be yeah yeah it would be we
would be saying hey projects so I look
at it and I'm like now I'm looking at
house I hold on I've got to watch that
inside Xbox you know that that series
that one day light I was nodding for
that and they killed with like a lot of
those games they look decent the only
ones I couldn't stand was that freaking
vampire game cuz it didn't look no type
of by gen we looked at mm there reppin
arrow he said both Xbox and PlayStation
branded these first two shows wrong so
what do you feel cuz they said it's the
future of gaming dinero I was just
curious about why you feel Oh continued
cave yeah cuz they yeah they made a lot
of the games that we wanted to I guess
wanted to see they didn't get the
biggest shine outside of right
Kling you know to me oh it's I remember
when they first introduced horizon the
first time right they did it with
gameplay mm-hmm this time it was just a
cinematic trailer you can't make a
proper judgment you got you got ugly no
you look like horizon zero dawn or in
the show people in the chat are burning
up look no one knows for 100% fact of
that spot it was a do see or not the way
the vibes they gave me it looks like I
do it looks like me looks like a
standalone game it could have been built
from the ground up yes maybe five cool
but it seemed like that it didn't seem
like it's shown me spider-man
to tech don't like it looks very much
like you could do that on a pier so pro
I feel like they just use that to
FULFILLER
it's like look we got this this great
game over here you're like they're gonna
use that game to connect the first to
write all this stuff up and hearing
about that special SSD be anything you
see today say yellow yes show me oh yeah
try to cap for the defend of a little
girl no no okay
you guys I know it's gonna be the next
generation is gonna be very hard to show
you yeah right because we're at a
graphical fidelity for you guys that
didn't make the leap to the X right this
is hard for me to explain to you if you
pick up an Xbox regular x-ray next box
one X right now the 4k draft is on stuff
right now is definitely top choice if
you pick up a PlayStation Pro the
checkerboard scaling on a 4k television
is definitely chopped choice what what
you're seeing is the height of what
we're getting right you see the
playstation trying to reach that how you
see the Xbox hitting that height right
now we're we want to get sustain
graphics when we get to the next
consoles and now I saw some framerate
stuff on erratically I'm not gonna hit
him in the head like that right now be
that game has to ship they were showing
you things when it was transitioning the
world yeah Freya Luthor when they was
pulling you into different dimensions
and different points in time you're not
doing that on your Playstation
so if you right if you're walking away
from that show talking about you didn't
see the SSD in effect I'm gonna have to
tell you no that's a lot because they
definitely showed you to Ratchet and
Clank and showed you something I don't
think that can be done on the
PlayStation 4 regular now it could be
wrong now I could be absolutely wrong
that's just me hoping that this is the
effect that I can get from them at the
same time this show was not it right
this is not it I know I kept for Xbox
right but I'm a console purchaser right
I purchased these consoles I purchased
these bangers now the the horizon zero
dawn beautiful underwater tanks go to a
new direction do the mountain stuff do
all that stuff good fantastic I like
that take it take it there for those
people that love that story take it
there I'm gonna go finish the first one
it put me to sleep not a true fan but
I'm running to purchase the second one
now that Ratchet and Clank definitely
want that yet the Gran Turismo was hot
trash compared to the Forza but for you
people that like Gran Turismo that Gran
Turismo is still wrong there's go-to
cars on the trail they show you problem
go by and X 4 to 7 eggs ok blaze thought
oh oh ok so go play Forza 7 that's
innocent Ruffolo I got I do got
something to say I do got some sad jet
starter wood how you feel blaze about
them coffee and the the the no disc
version of the other sad what's going on
there what's going on there blaze I
thought PlayStation doesn't copy off
Xbox again
[Applause]
came in with a xbox hat and an xbox
she'll just oh so well he's our he was
ready to switch sides
and shout out to all Sony fans that was
ready to switch up at the same pace I
feel you guys but at no point in time
was I coming here with a sony shirt and
it's so nothing I told you Xbox all date
and officially y'all showed me nothing
to be afraid about but I'm gonna tell
you in July
I'm your kneecaps I got a lot of knees
coming to me now yeah question day in a
row spot on a super swap and get a joker
nano Joker with the two loops at why
they open up with the game one was ten
years old it was GTA seven I'm like what
you better bring it on weapon wheel
don't let bond come for your neck on
Sunday that PS 5 looks huge versus the
controller 76 with an axe law game past
fuller which they have to pay look
pretty but again unless unless you tell
me with that that you don't have bangers
at launch and this is how you guys are
gonna gonna ride the wave like they did
ps4 yeah then you might find an audience
for that on the ps4 at launch if you
don't have bangers in fact fax that
stuff in a service you PSPs people on
buying those games now oh we got our two
dollars to pour concrete genies super
affiliate ago somebody making me with
that water element appeal to lhasa chat
worse NBA 2k teaser ever sweat in the
bushes
shoud the slow file a subject okay
project Athiya ratcheting plan yes
Horacio - yes Miles Morales and Kino
Kino Kino Kino is the forest 101 with
the little bit with the girl in the
middle and the only ones that impress
death loop is okay show was mid buying
that ps5 digital though right okay yo
one real question you if Sony is pushing
the PlayStation 5 mm-hmm
and then gonna show you things that can
only be done on a Playstation 5 why
start off with a DLC I didn't like to
start I thought that was a bad choice I
could only I know I mean no no this is
that we know they started off a grandma
I'm talking about when the bangistan
when I woke up um kind of spider-man
right yeah now what you just told me is
go keep your playstation because we got
this for that game that we we know that
the game of the year that is the one of
our best games on our platform to keep
the senior minds I'll let y'all know
what it's not coming anytime soon right
so go back to play your PlayStation 4
yeah because they cannot get away with
putting that DLC or whatever it is on
the PS 5 on everywhere if you had a good
question know how much storage do we
think the digital edition will have to
get to 2 bytes no I I think it's got the
same amount cuz they're gonna try to say
oh they're gonna save on price I don't
think they're good oh action you saving
on the disk drive really $35 my boys sim
is mad at us he said the DLC spider-man
not a DLC he said we hate in hard right
now he's coming up abuse war let's go
man here's our man who said so waiting
on price and date of course but as of
this afternoon I am hard Xbox team Wow
Joey says PS 5 looks like a spider-man
foundation future suit blames how would
you feel
seriously mmm
if they told you like you saw infamous
second son and they gave you that other
one with it with the girl right and I
would never set that was separate right
but that was all inside the same on the
same console actually actually purchased
their everything would you go for that
happy to PlayStation five I mean no I
mean that's it's fine that looks it
looks hot that's my game it II that's my
god yes five only for that I would be a
little time one thing that we do gotta
talk about is that down grave remember
when we saw it first at the Game Awards
it look they look crazy and what we see
in of the actual gameplay look a game
may be fun but I did not it did not look
graphically impressive and remember I
was telling you a couple weeks ago that
I'm interested in golf all boy and now
I'm not a kid to finish his balls off
because I'm good yeah I'm good at the
show I'm happy to show the console I'm
happy to show around zero Don but it
wasn't nothing spectacular
you know people tried to warn me say hey
I need to be you know I beat we gotta be
scared I were scared and honestly I'm
like okay Brown aye
yeah I thought I need at the out for at
present like man they go on and they
play see she's gonna come hard and do
your thing but dude they seem very
humbled bro a they need to promote
Yoshida get him out that seat bruh where
the I know he wants to show some love to
the Indies and
but not but the thing that just seemed
really tone-deaf was after they reeled
off about 40 minutes of those ABC games
hunter hearst-helmsley it says you know
we enjoy showing you guys the games
that's only possible on playstation 5
and I'm like wait watching all of that
is only on PlayStation everything is so
everything that you saw can only be done
when the police got out to play shout to
homie blade cuz on he's definitely Sony
in a building he said you guys said they
said no PlayStation got five games will
not run on PlayStation 4 shot the black
ice he said it's an insult to 110
million PlayStation 4 owners that the
spider-man game isn't cross-gen
interesting which I feel I believe
that's a little bit of consistent below
let's get into soft song but let's get
it's your first live with the noise I
just read you this is the thing to me
right like I want people when people are
running around so box with the ps4 they
had the greatest single big my thing is
you gotta remember where you came from
and that's energy wasn't an ps3 PS 20
was known for having weird small indie
games until they started with the
bangles with the were infamous and
infamous too and obviously Last of Us
and the Uncharted trilogy and stuff like
that they they they kind of had to
survive with that in the beginning same
way they did with the ps4 so my thing is
like I said before like these games if
at launch you don't have a banger these
games will find an audience at launch if
they're there if not the PS audience is
what you've already a clementa them to
expect third-person over-the-shoulder
action game bang a looking game like
it's gonna be a tough sell without
putting those games inside a service and
in like I said before you have that's
how you make PS now a little bit more
appealing it's not game pass levels
appealing but you make it a little more
appealing by putting those games in
there otherwise I don't think they sell
on that platform beyond that like I said
um Ratchet and Clank look great the Sony
want to pay these developers to continue
support
this is my thing right in the beginning
is all love two years in in when the
bangers are ready to go right they throw
him on the curb like it like a stepchild
so I don't know what that is it's gonna
be his honest man he said yeah keep
taking the spot of being a deal see this
show is spooky he was like how y'all
easy yes I got no y'all too salty do the
roof because we keep saying it's wrong
if you tell me that that the the Miles
Morales expansion is only for pier five
right and I'm a ps4 owner and uh if I if
I'm choosing not to upgrade right at the
beginning I'm gonna be mad right I got I
got I got a counter
let's all be real here in this chat hmm
if that was spider-man if that was the
next sequel that was a sequel to
spider-man 1 it would be called
spider-man 2 they wouldn't they wouldn't
tried that like okay first off a lot of
people don't you know miles is you know
sure you you'll know B if you're a you
know you're a spider-man if you're a
spider-man person you would know that
but it's just like you got a huge
demographic of people that's like that's
not spider-man to like I just think that
that's not going to be good like it has
to be standalone it just has to be to me
like I feel like if you if that was the
sequel they would have named it
spider-man 2 and then miles or whatever
his last name is right you know I didn't
know miralles my morality I just feel
like it's one of those things to where
someone said it's horizon sequel called
horizon - didn't what it cauterised -
all right no horizon now you listen man
his energy is dead man and you know what
I came in here you listen because listen
they were telling me oh you know blade
since last week blades I'm not gonna lie
it was like your blades you know that
let's do this over the hill your side
you'll say he definitely be reppin then
you know you join the realm
much respect right and you definitely
super chat much respect then I
definitely seen you engaging on Twitter
much respectful so I'm coming in today I
came in with my ain't game you already
heard when I came in I came in ready
a game I'm talking to cog last night he
was hitting balls I was oh yeah it got
worse when it got lots got worse one got
lost but the thing is this and a lot of
the PlayStation do's have the energy
then when they actually seen it happen
energy is leaving out of them now I'm
not gonna front Christopher Hart he's
still it I got I got I got to give you
that love Chris because you are captain
Hart now I know you getting a digital
edition because the $700 won't be in
your price range
it's definitely caught horizon - she was
small so the chance he said he's just
because I was not agreeing with the
whole you know the the spider-man not
being you know ma he said I was being
racist
oh yeah stop that come on you don't have
to do big you finally super check I left
it came back we still talk about that
rationalism did we miss a bunch of
smoothy smooth ones we got a chat there
is no greater power than X to book again
two dollar super Jack got four looks
like peasant Jonathan be a lesson came
back no very we miss Victor Alice teen
to awesome chat boy alright H I pursuing
horizon zero dawn and said i JD to look
good but was not gameplay that was not
gameplay exactly well underwater look
baby yeah pixel BG - okay guys saw PS 5
is is PS 5 is 4 is the height of the
controller for I didn't get that second
point yeah um yeah ok yeah game you know
you don't know because you're allergic
this quarter you won't jump
actually I delete that delete I know I
heard all right yeah I put that in the
tell you what you the first time I see
you live me Lloyd Banks tune it I wanted
to be ready but you come off so does
that not say - between the forbid and
west and horizons that does until y'all
sit - y'all you got it no it's okay it's
okay
this is dis aspiring fun you know this
is this is what we do on Saturday this
is you know game talk all right so
there's no sides across the street okay
I want people to understand that you
know there's there's no side to dis
against we all gone we all own
everything you just show the xu oanh you
show system you understand so all that
people think oh you know you'll be a
fool if you purchase one console look at
the other have the money to purchase the
next time so I'm going l no I don't like
that something mentally wrong with the
individual so you know like I said I got
my PlayStation I never had to bust this
out but you know the Box because this
was day one open it neither revive the
controller like times I mean mine is
messing up and we got game advisor to
follow chess so if they released you
today five on next-gen how many copies
are you gonna sell out of all the games
that they show that's the one I wanted
most not sure they're curious that
they're you gonna make another GT at
this point I told you carry them until
they have ready that Red Dead has to be
in the same position at the Gran Turismo
before they make that leap so that's why
I thought that we're gonna show the red
remix of one listen it was a list that I
got in the background I'm not gonna I'll
cheat dude I'm not gonna out you some of
the stuff you did say was right other
stuff was dead wrong and I'm I'm
laughing at my list was even better than
this and I'm going on your yeah we got
Eagles fan 76020 super chat how many
launch games three I saw on the show no
I had an issue with that I was my beef
some of them they didn't even show over
at least a like not even not even don't
really I wouldn't know I was my Ratchet
and Clank is day one everything else oh
yeah yes anyone gets my neck you didn't
get that Mac three and I guess because
they was getting such a negative
publicity about it I believe they cut
that out of the snippet you're messy
like he put on Twitter
ps5 about to get that Taco Bell market
back with a cheesy credo crutch inspired
design raised to say yo Xbox up in some
feelings you know what I mean though
there are people that liked it co feel
of the show so yeah hope you in red
dragon well that doesn't surprise me 76
after there's how many day one or wait
till 2021 good question the question is
like why would you have to buy it day
one let's be real there like like
console war stuff stuff aside even the
series acts like I mean there's nothing
for both of them coming out and we don't
know what the first party issue when you
live but no but but Xbox said that all
their games is gonna run on the cuz I
got and you got a regular joint what's
the difference I'm telling you the 1080p
different telling me what it is so show
you telling me this is like a difference
like okay let's say the series X so I
get to series X it's gonna look like
golf ball when they reveal it if I get
the fine now it's gonna look like the
show today
you know what people downplay like the
pros in the eggs like yo it's a big
difference
yeah I'm sorry it's a big hassle the
high resolution makes a big difference
you're not getting [ __ ] yeah
anything personal shout-out to
spider-man terrassa [ __ ] had just left
a Sony channel the damage control is
real look let's get some balls off lifts
off finishes yeah we'll see we'll see I
don't think the look at the console I
prefer black console I think it's just
the design listen the the series X looks
like a rocket launcher because it needs
to look like a rocket launcher like this
man it just looks look it's trying it's
like it's trying to look hot just take a
look at hot I don't know Josh ready
Lords of game with that nice at what
damage crow would control that show was
awesome that is low as it gave it that
this I got that's that's the
editor-in-chief right okay so II Marie
with Chad they said it says the birds
just posted a pic of PS 5 on its side
okay let me get to event um here's a do
you know you start off you say it's the
future of gaming right the same energy
you said it is the future of gaming we
get in there okay let first a plus we
got the console I'm loving that
Horacio don't we expect it is grant we
expect it and then look to me phenomena
I will say there was some points with
grants original and I did look okay how
many cars on a screen but graphically
the models look phenomenal
you know for me again I told people
coming in to what kid King was saying
remember the list that kind of King
thought was gonna happen was I thought
was gonna happen right that list was
impressive but I for for me like I I
didn't have like a game for me like how
gonna sashimi is for me right and
Horacio doing is cool it's just not
necessarily like I don't go crazy you
know I'm saying grant demon souls I know
people love it I'm not a soul that so I
don't Chris I needed something for me
that's gonna say okay that's for you to
hold out to get a ps5 and then the other
thing that I think I'm most disappointed
with is release day see this
is the Saudi stuff that I get matter and
I gotta call it out I gotta call out you
know it's cool to show a trailer and all
that know what I look a fly but when is
it coming out when are we getting it and
all I'm concerned about is launch lineup
on day one when I cop a ps5 what am I
getting and for me right now I get I got
a relook at it maybe you're getting a
headache
that's all you get him right now I don't
see nothing for four Cognito
I get it yeah like some of these games
guys if you guys are Ratchet and Clank
don't let my hate sway you the game with
my nominal is just not for me so for me
I'm like what is for me and I'm Dax
about a little that's my inner turmoil
right now Damon does have a release date
no no and that's that again what is
going to be all launch when I kept up
one thing's for sure we know we got an
idea of what Xbox series acts in front
of both are we hoping most likely Halen
win finning I mean they said Yakuza they
said a couple of games that I say the
medium a medium they said it gonna be
those again again people rip me for
loving the third party show from Xbox
they said in a shuttle game play
rightfully so they didn't show gameplay
but a lot of those games is similar and
a lot of those games I was interested
then we gotta get straight to this
kiddie game edge energy I gotta get to
it all during this generation all we
hear is stops you guys got all 4k and
there's no power from next by the wind
when is they gonna showcase the power I
got a key stand tall I didn't see
anything for the most part
besides horizon which is not coming out
this year that wowed me that looked like
the next generation of game like I
didn't see that mi brazo no you right
okay look what now oh I got a count at
all I got a count on when they was on
the track there was only one over cone
I do want to get I want to ask them
round one thing hmm what like do you
think this helps Microsoft in July 100%
like if they do what Sony's been able to
do in the past is come behind them and
look at the mistakes they've made and
to fire them then Microsoft knows from
the from the rhetoric coming out of it
right they know they got it they got a
bang-up thing of me if they have for
Mike the song if does what they're
supposed to do is set up for them is
literally underhanded to the Microsoft
got definitely the cubox there's no more
shows for you alright last point so
great hey there's my last point and this
is I'm no perhaps not I am we've gone
back and forth shout out the ring
because we had a good conversation about
this coming in and a lot of people were
a lot of Xbox fans were very you know
because I really like you know they
could come me you ever say I know you
we've know what squid girl but I'm just
saying a lot of Xbox fan or not you'll
be proud of what I just posted on now we
need them need I posted this early to
you guys and all I'm saying is when I
tell people this we know the pedigree we
know they got the games but us blaze is
right we know they will come with the
games that they accustomed to and it's
like we already know just like a DC
shout out the temp dog with the
PlayStation 5 already listen all I'm
saying is that from a regime change you
have to see how the company moves we
expect the great Sony all the time
remember this is not late in this is not
you know your sheet is in a different
role now Nick they definitely went indie
with him you see that but no one has a
space heater no you can't compete they
got us with the free
generated older refrigerators you know
no one says those are funny but you
don't get this one take away all I'm
saying is I get week with a regime
change you gotta see it in launch window
they've no tourists at least from every
console console I've had they no
tourists not had like a like this oh
they don't bust their gun emission right
that's what I was saying like it's in
the middle they heat up and and then
each banger comes on as the generation
continue to go and now that's all I'm
saying but I agree in this disrespect
right like I said is before it you know
if if the P if the way from ps4
continues right you could expect it to
sell super well right maybe even more
than XL launch now the thing about that
is what's different now the Energy's
different is that the narrative going in
is much different the narrative you in
it the narrative isn't the you know Xbox
has a weaker console the narrative is an
Xbox is watching you in your living room
the narrative is and also all they need
to do is come correct in July and the
narrative going into launch is different
now what I do think you never know
because I listen I've had conspiracy
theories about you know
snatching defeat victory from the door
yeah bikes I'll be doing the bungle slam
so it just seems like I don't know like
though it seems like the underhand lob
is there for Microsoft if they have the
bang is to take advantage me let me ask
blaze this question Oh blaze um as
former all right we know we the hawk all
we get unless we are be anyone no matter
you getting Bob like this is cold with
it but my question to you blaze is like
for a guy who's on the fence Duda has a
ps4 do you think enough was shown for
them to get it day when I guess is my
question
absolutely okay okay absolutely oh no
look look you know me I'm a PlayStation
1 I'm fear dude I'm not delusional like
son oh okay
and that conference was it was it a
little lackluster was a lot of cream
filling in the middle like I said cuz
there's not gonna be available oh my god
so you're gonna tell me that they did
they told you ahead of time they're not
gonna have as many units as you want it
to be so when you already limit your
money in your wallet that's like going
to a strip club but only fifty dollars
in your pocket cause you ain't got spend
more to you so that's great there you
put yourself at the RIP but again you
don't sit there and tell me you're not
gonna get a chance to get out of this
one right now tell me oh you know our
track record show notes what was the
show show show me yeah yeah the question
is written is this again the question is
it was anything shown that's gonna make
you buy a Playstation and if those games
didn't even have a date then it's the h2
the no because only thing that's gonna
be Tia add a day one we know for a fact
they're gonna want true one of their
bang is only banging it I saw that was
further along its Ratchet and Clank so
Ratchet and Clank day one we already
know gran turismo is not coming out
until you got five millions so so you
can just put that to the bushes right so
now you're gonna get some of those
fillers that's gonna be in the middle of
there was any of those fillers so game
pass fill as those stuff that she was
talking about that's not ready for you
to purchase with any of those things
that stuff that you want to buy he'll to
the notes but from you right you gonna
buy but we Tommy that got their four
hundred five hundred dollars they say
you know what should I upgrade I have a
Playstation pro right now should I go
all the way up or should I just wait a
little bit until they get the catalog
record but but King are in in Sony's
defense being that they're standing on
their square with yo these PS 5 games
ain't playing and that you know that
what you call it at spider-man and
some stuff like don't you think that
dudes might get weak spider-man if they
do that - that spite him millions of
people that purchase spider-man and if
they do that to you did you change the
engine or Dave are you just doing this
out of spite just to get the cash grab
is this a cash grab for me right are you
trying to capitalize on my friend I feel
like it's not consumer friend let's just
and we know and we don't know if it's a
full price game right that's right watch
it dude a charge $60
it better be 1995 then but it better be
the price of the deal G with the to
which that PS 5 is the reverse Oreo yes
it is JD with that I'm happy I got to
see the strawberry everybody will be
exactly like the disc I think that I
think that's the thing that I think if
there's anything they really surprised
me on was the fact that they came out
with a diskless version because they
know that the price of that regular
version is not what that PlayStation
based wants so they're gonna try to
bring down that right do you think the
SSD is gonna be smaller because I don't
think you have enough of a reduction in
price just removing the disc drives I
don't know slot into channel he said
both designs console design not gonna
plan it um we hold on yeah hello metal
pol Emily you get how much cheaper with
a PS 5 sad B dollar cheaper without the
camera whoa it's going to be and yeah my
getting yeah I think it's gonna be the
same price Wow okay I think it's going
to be the same price I think so these
tiny recoup some bread on the system I
think the hard drive is gonna be bigger
I don't think I think I think the hard
drive is having a different skew if it's
the same price it's gonna be it's either
gonna be cheaper or the hard drives
gonna be bigger
there's no in-between if it's the same
exact innards right yeah see the
Lockhart movie known so far or what we
heard so far is that in that can change
at any point right that it's a lesser
version of the Dex
right so we we already automatically
assume being that you have inferior
parts to the accent is not gonna be
comparable to price and we don't believe
that it's gonna be a hard disk drive
inside so we we figure that it be 299
that 300 price range right we don't know
if this is going to be a lesser inferior
product to if is the PlayStation 5 is
that the pro and is this the less
inferior product to it like a digital
version I gotta take them as face value
right pinkie the same exact thing I did
that and I think the storage medium is
exactly what they're trying to get
because the biggest problem is when your
storage size is only is not even a
terabyte in a terabyte you're gonna have
people build off with it so if them the
two terabyte or the six I was here is 16
something oh so you think they give them
because it's digital all right I think
they give them a bigger terabyte joint
right and if you're basing is it no disk
okay I see what you're going with that
because expect them to down behave if
you have a DC super channel Mario Mario
so we got a final super cell for Mariano
keep that same energy this sony was was
all right the system reveal saved the
show showed Microsoft reveal the price
in July for both series X and s I need
wings damn might have to but system
beyond they don't have to hold on to it
to be honest with you I think he's
really all let's get some artists
something's in the chat I don't know if
that's in there yet but uh if they
wouldn't have revealed the card to sit
the show at the system I think it would
have been way worse on big G - awesome
check how do you share games on PS 5 I'm
third hip hop to take that bet with me
he no no
the behind Lawrence alone I mean have
you squared yes we got so Anthony Boyd
with the sudah super chat now that we've
seen both who gonna drop price first
good question I think Microsoft SkyDrive
first black matrix especially after that
show today now they're like those games
ps5 games look better than last of us on
the pro none of it did and got a $2.00
tip jar for true Kingdom you King you
Pete that card readers swipe on the
inside drive that was will you slide
your credit card or Edwards better not
be any 30 frames on next-gen PRS race
what else we go we gotta find out
supercar from state guys 23 I don't care
if it's the cardboard box with hose as
long as it has great games day one
series X and 2021 PlayStation 5 both
will be less hey guys no Doug gable by
choice final switch at diskless cannot
be the same price unless they put extras
in controller or added games or
subscription of PS news for the room
right now is just gotta say one thing is
this a W word I'll give a number let's
give a number y'all come on let's go
down a little we got to be messy but
give it a numbers for show let's give a
number that was the kiss move seven okay
alright we know Wow before he gets his
bars on we need some into the bushes and
some fraud alerts in that chat for our
board boy no moduli respecting us with
kappa now you say seven
he definitely can stand on that square
good lad blaze get his balls out why is
it a ten so it's the perfect shot so
then also he's the PlayStation do they
move the goalposts we already know the
games are gonna be today we don't know
if you'll survive next year odds right
now there's a different this is a
different league it's coming for you and
when a really it's there the fight is
over that's the difference is what we're
gonna do is you can come back that day
when in July this is this how strong I
am on that square you can come back that
day and I guarantee you we rockin that X
right there the corner with the light
shining up with the X hat on with the X
jacket on in the background signing with
the X I can guarantee you that's what
that's a show that you're gonna walk
away with money you gonna throw the
money at the screen money in my pocket
today I saw oh listen listen
ready you're ready to let's save this
for ILP let's say the business is blaze
I honestly would tell you from the
bottom of my heart this is emotional you
know I would like for you to just walk
away with you I'll I made a video
towards you but the other diss track
ready
Square salute you died on us or at least
we should get to see the series s now I
think that hope is the door if it's a
question for kid can how you fill that
knack 3 was announced it may show you
more under woman but I did get retching
and clink so I am hype arrested clink
but the disappointing they didn't say
anything about lunch or holiday 2020 so
it was like here dear lunch line up you
look a spooky on the Rilke Cognito you
need you need to you need to cut that
out of the other youtuber put that all
to it and that was I lost literally
could not breathe y'all going a little
woozy burped on on Twitter Oh who's
Ebert that's that man that's wicked and
he is literally me and Boston in fact it
was my dude so he's joking guys he is a
jerk or they all lose your head be going
it seems like you're your king with
those knees that and you know dudes is
not trying to hit it please my man alone
Lee who's Ebert alone please chatterbox
yeah
shout out the boss you already know
being on a building so blaze Fisher
balls let's get at it
overall I got I just want to make a
we're saving that freyal hold on
that I'm getting so I guarantee you
easily accept your bet because I'm
accepting a lot of it before I accept
the hell out of your bet one they're
gonna launch before you two
they're gonna have more available now
you know going in only told you it's
scaling back
how many Playstations going to be
available and you still want to take
this weirdo bet but we're talking month
we're talking about we're on year or two
the year so if you launch a most behind
with a limited stock okay
again I'm listen right listen something
like from January 2021 to December 21
then I can have a decent that's a decent
bet for you but he's talking he's
talking launch you know he saw no did
the launch is the launch Windows to
Christmas that's it so imma give me a
launch window when it come out -
Christmas question about to get to the
end of Christmas that's not good for you
right so let's go a game together so um
so some very great bird just posted up
congrats to our friends of Saudi on
their show today Xbox might should know
titles like GTA 5 3 NBA 2k this one I
can
one of the pragma game is that way dice
game are gonna look and play oh yo
congrats to our friends at Saudi funny
you know what's funny people was
wondering if that Resident Evil village
was exclusive and he went up there's
like Naga he even put pregnant and did
he put pragmatic etc yo like it's more
games there's go why he said many game
presentation respect the bars greedy
yeah
all right let me tell you something
right yo blaze let me tell you something
they respond right after yeah you're
dealing with dealing with a totally
different beast don't be confused with
the dudes that wanted to get out of the
magic this is this is filled with money
now confused with the dudes I wanted to
go services you're dealing with Spartan
warriors in the beginning they wanted to
just go TV and all that others that they
brought stole instead of buying
developments of houses you know why I
tried to give you the way out
you know why you say you know what I
want to do mad at you and I'm and you
know what I want you listen and I want
to gift wrap the blaze infinity though
yo saw this Mariano Papa for you you
gotta say it you gotta say it very
strong
Mariano Papa
you know what with the fellas you know
how we there is a worth upgrading at
launch keep the same energy added Europe
get to it baby
I gotta give it a seven out of ten
and no I'll give it a eight because the
comments I think did save it a little
bit I'll give it an eight because I did
enjoy like you know they had the
Resident Evil in there you know they had
that death straining wannabe game in
there I I'm saying the presentation was
trash I didn't mind the games it's just
how they hiked it they said this is the
future of gaming place the future know
kognito did I not call Microsoft for
they nonsense when they say how they
marketed they stuff - did I not say it
but I was vigorously won I was the only
one in the Google Chat that was that
that was reppin I I keep it consistent
ways it was okay show at the end like
they had a lot of fluff in the middle
that could not have been there they had
some decent stuff at the end that the
demon souls the Resident Evil I don't
even know what to call that because that
doesn't feel like a sequel to me but it
is what it is that's a nice stuff at the
beginning I can't have like the men at
the beginning and the end did not exist
because the middle was all garbage
there's a lot of it was I didn't show
the console was in a seven out of ten
showing the call to gay be gay and the
console look good the console looks in
my opinion looks better than the series
acts like somebody put a soft taco in
the microwave too long it's aiways the
only way it's it's sideways is on that
pedestal so the pedestal keeps it
while we did that death loop in Tokyo
guevara our playstation five exclusive
know what so let it be yeah crying is it
a tear in my eye and that they will not
be played on xbox no more games
on the deaf loop and it goes why a Tokyo
but that's the joint those games I think
if they say Larry herb is being messy
right now on Twitter let me see all
along they told all the Microsoft you
know Soames tower in the Lord of the
Rings yes the tower in the eyes at the
top yo they still yeah they be a messy
day yeah a baby game every game s it
knows right he's like yo explain our
rockstars GTA 5 expanded enhance so
series X he was like congrats to our
friends in Saudi he does the air agree
that he says Capcom announced his
Resident Evil pragmatic he says two more
great games coming to the series thought
we got to start closing yeah we got it
cool look oh you got your Jojo it off um
sob you got your it off yeah I mean I
gave it a 7 and that's because they
showed the console absolutely absolutely
yo it was gonna be I mean let me tell
you something that show was definitely a
four it was absolutely for I'm gonna
keep it a buck which is not even your
kiddie games look better than grounded
so I'm gonna give you a full yeah that's
right though your head back video for
right because I'm playing grounded
tomorrow while you waiting to play that
whack stuff
Oh games right there that's all you got
is dreams I'm all for all that smoke
don't do it so chase with the tool of
super chat ps5 looks fine let's just
hope it does it doesn't catch fire
extinguisher comes with it Oh new red is
jokes brother on switches those shades
jokes so it was really gonna be a fall
for me and I said if they don't show the
console it was a fail I got eight oh she
said why they got an eight now let me
give you a reason why they got a eight
mm-hmm she's gonna have that but they
got the two points for the console show
right mm-hmm
they got another two points for telling
you we got a sad Edition okay all right
so this so this is them putting a foot
out trying to smoke Microsoft Mouse I'm
watching and you could tell how they
marketed that Saturday they wanted that
to be a of what the hell moment because
at first it showed the other one and
then it like they would away in the
transition and then it still did them
both together wait wait say that again
King I love the fact and I'm uh that's
what that's what adequate saying I love
the fact that they showed you that they
they're trying right and they they're
going to try a understate respect it did
you you gotta look it's a big thing I'm
having to visualization right and the
old Sony digital really wasn't there
they're lame they wasn't really trying
to you know push you in that area
because they kept telling you about
physical and physical sales and physical
lists and physical that but now with the
digital edition only new they're
embracing that going forward the
PlayStation now and Iraq right so that
this does this make me optimistic going
forward the PlayStation now will
actually start to look and reflect how
game pass is because if it does then I'm
a purchaser and I'm part of that
ecosystem
and I'd be partner and they get more
engagement from me and that's all I ever
want so do I think there will be hit say
go collect your knees kick kick
collective beeswax full I'm Santa Claus
with these needs so eight because a
console and the fact that they've
changed pivot on digital direction with
far as embracing a digital future only
console okay thanks let me get these
guys before yeah before look I can't
believe I'm coming lower the king they
saying it this wasn't it for me even
with what's funny is how is cognate oh
but to have a higher score than me and
King good yeah I got a higher score to
be just look as a game I gotta do I
gotta pull a attic it's it's cog beetles
world right now forgotten right I wasn't
high I wasn't dead like eat like I will
say this as much as I'm clown a lot of
the indie game some of those indie games
look unique and cool I didn't like the
minion join like I know even though I'm
going hard or as far as the presentation
I'll just do that because as far as the
energy when Xbox will show those type of
games right but overall don't you know
some of those Indians didn't look cool
and I like to design a lot of unique
stuff specially that uh this Destruction
Derby Germany jump out the car like
rocket League I like the minions join
but they had a lot of original concept I
like what Shuhei is doing with and I
don't care what nobody say the game that
I thought was resogun they're little
like Mass Effect with desire fire so the
Indies actually were more five just too
many of them is it but it was more fire
but overall it was gonna be it's
something we don't expect from from them
and then you can't for me you can't say
this is the future of gaming right tune
in for the future and and you get
majority of those tiles I love games
overall it was a solid show but as me
coming in what am I getting ps5 for ikat
launched at launch we know blazed up
is a stable you know what horizons gonna
come whenever it does release I was
surprised with the racket executive
released
no no that surprised me I thought that
was definitive launching I'm saying
grant we notice all the motors didn't
have release dates
that's notice the console didn't even
say like holiday of 2020 well they took
that off to notice notice how like none
of these games said like launch title or
anything right well yes all I'm saying
so for me selfishly I just needed that
one title that was gonna be there when I
cop you don't you get your new system
you got that game you want to show off
blade you know you want to like no this
is why I control and nobody here neither
how are you betting but for me it was a
seven that was like that because the
console console was was don't we father
I'm real sure would better we gotta
catch up on these super chance you get
out Smitty Smith would define our super
Jack Microsoft pulled the curtain off
The Wizard of Oz those games are gonna
be an Xbox series X laugh out loud and
then we have gamers play with the Philo
super chat Xbox just put up a video with
dirt five devs showing how they can take
advantage of series X 125 people was
laughing at that show and it was like
why they show all them games look
next-gen and look like yo to me most of
them gays love next-gen and most of them
games is ready for the Lord that's four
months a I'm I'm excited for what's
launched when I caught my series X
that's what I'm COBOL that was what we
know I an internal type game but you
can't say don't look if somebody doesn't
have a television I can take advantage
of that protect and I understand it
right and the majority of people shout
out to the new person sort of around but
the crowd you know listen you must play
now gamers play you have definitely
entered yourself and a chance to get to
that Xbox series X I know that that you
know the chance to win it at is
definitely let's get LaMarcus das pretty
quick
he said Xbox capital for dirt dirt has a
release
sir your [ __ ] make sure before you go
out we give them more year for us we get
all I'm sorry gran turismo below Marcus
what's the release date when is when are
you getting it that's what I'm trying to
say like we could sit there and we could
cap audience I can tell you two floors
on launch LaMarcus what are you getting
that you're excited for you're gonna see
Forza instant July I bet my knees on
that and I can tell you that whatever
follows is gonna show more car yo these
guys just go shot the den that's our bug
that's our season game and brother David
yes what's up bro shout the g-man mm
check will sad games play on PS 6 with
this all shout the blades but the
chatter but that's not like everybody
got off cuz we got to get out of here
your Sunday gonna be late
y'all ready yeah I got a preview
whoo-hoo the legendary Sony guess we'll
be you know say so we got some fun in a
row man yes the reason we get that $2
super trap from G please please forget
that we got a $2 oh we got it we got
that and let's see another one
what the - ugh whatever $2 super Gmail
will sad games play on PS 6 yeah we got
that so everybody that's it yo just do
our chores get up out of here
Lord blaze for Kate wake of the fire
people find you in it you got going on
sir in the realm really appreciated
great show guys I don't know what you
say now put your knees up there oh yeah
we got another person show in the realm
let's put the shields up yes sir well we
got a $10 gene oh yeah JD gamer get up
soft
we got JD game with the $10 super chat I
just want those that were saying - scuse
will confuse people and leave all day
every day until launch I would love to
see all the multiplayer better on the X
listen don't leave we're going to be
telling you about the giveaway
do not leave we don't do that enjoy
but yeah so there are EXO shot the blaze
gave us all join with your kiss smooth
the best way we can define people
finally what you got going on sir
you guys can find me on Twitter I'm
getting things live over there people
getting upset at me already but uh yeah
I'll be on Twitter follow me there and
I'll be checking out ILP this Sunday of
course I'm Hannity bill is gonna be lit
and of course Lord addict with the new
videos out with the hot tub nails we're
gonna find Cooper find you well
apparently my thumbnails are kicking it
over there on Twitter here recently you
can find me on Twitter at Lord addict
ILP you can find me on youtube at gaming
addicts and you can find me going to
sleep after that show mm-hmm oh my god
Lord saw was going on first live
reactions with the Lords then I'll shout
out to my homie big cloud gaming in the
building what's up bro
man man shot the are GT facts shadow GT
was good or so I'm sorry so if you go to
work that's what you doing I should have
gone to work oh damn JDK won't let us
leave mm which I only 250 in the realm
it that like button for short stays tool
for the joint Lord King was fearless I
have to commend this man has been on his
square despite so much abuse how are you
feeling so I we're gonna find revenge oh
I'm feeling fantastic I'm feeling great
when I told you I was playing that Elton
John joint and it was I'm still standing
I'm still standing video coming so part
two yes
I'll see that kos in the back yeah get
that statue that Joe just a day see the
new logo I love to build it you know
what it is
King David OTW or Twitter also follow me
on youtube with the kos go to loads of
game and dotnet listen stick around to
hear how you can get an Xbox series X
and we're gonna be trying to get y'all
guys a Playstation 5 once we can narrow
it down to figure out what's going on
um but might be a sad addition the
markets are still mad with us he said of
course Xbox guy said he went to sleep
but loved that boring inside Xbox
Oh at least every game from inside Xbox
I know I'll be getting this year I've
gotta cut that that was a blow yeah
Yuri don't look I get on 20 or Sonny's
gonna be late you know everybody enjoyed
it for rockin out where there's 250 300
strong good to see all the members all
that yo we gonna hit you out with this
promo your Rini will be her shea butter
is already rated down yeah it's right
well you know what it is the race is
mine get this promo y'all we will see
y'all around Sunday peace hi I'm Lord
King David of iron Lords podcast and
we're bringing to you an exciting new
giveaway this giveaway is like none
other
we'll be giving away an Xbox Series X
that's right you heard me right the
brand new console launching from
Microsoft this year well this is how
you're able to be part of that giveaway
there's two ways to get your name thrown
in the head for the raffle one become a
member of the realm that's hit that joy
button hit hit that jar your button you
hit that joint button down at the bottom
and you can become a member and also
another way is by becoming a patreon
member so you can be part of the realm
as well now this is brought to you by
cat daddy fat stacks a member and lord
of the realm a very generous person
that's in our community and this
community is beautiful so remember you
can have one entry by hitting that joint
button and becoming a member of the
realm and also you can have another
entry by being a patreon
now this a king what if I'm a member of
both well your name gets thrown in the
Hat two times so please like follow us
subscribe join or become a patreon
member or become both and your name is
in the Hat to get that Xbox series X as
to who did therefore you sweepstakes
this is wonderful this is something that
I'm sure that you will enjoy oh man have
a great